hey everyone
i welcome you all to simply learn
in today's session
we will discuss about types of
statistical studies
a statistical study is a four-step
process that begins by asking the right
questions
the steps are to collect appropriate
data and organize and analyze the data
to arrive at a proper conclusion
so
in this session
we'll discuss
what types of statistical studies are
used to finally arrive at the conclusion
there are mainly three types of
statistical studies the first one is
observational study
the second one is sample
and the third are the experiments
let's discuss each one of them in detail
observational study
an observational study is when
researchers are looking at the effect of
some types of intervention risks a
diagnostic test or treatment
without trying to manipulate who or what
the subject is
there is no interference on the research
subjects
let's try to understand this with the
help of an example
suppose researchers investigate the link
between the use of cell phones and the
brain cancer
there are two variables in the study
one is the extent of the cell phone
usage and the second one is whether the
person has a brain cancer previously or
not
both variables are measured for the
group of people
this is an observational study
there was no attempt to influence
people's cell phone usage to see if
different levels of users made any
difference in whether or not a person
developed the brain cancer
the next one is sample study
in statistics a sample is an analytical
subset of a larger population
the use of samples allow researchers to
conduct their studies with more
manageable data and in a timely manner
randomly drawn samples do not have much
bias if they are large enough but
achieving such a sample may be expensive
and time consuming
let's understand this with the help of
an example
suppose a company has 800 female
employees and 200 male employees
you want to ensure that the sample
reflects the gender balance of the
company so you sort the population into
strata based on gender
then you use a random sampling on each
group
by selecting 80 women and 20 women
respectively which will give you the
representative sample of 100 people
now you can conduct your statistical
analysis on these hundred people to
arrive at a larger conclusion
the last one is experimental study
experimental studies involve the random
assignment of participants into
different groups
in order to determine the casual effect
of a certain conditions on a certain
outcome
supposedly an observational study
indicated a certain type of trees did
not have much termite damage as the
other trees
researchers wondered
if the resins from the trees were toxic
to termites so they decided to do an
experiment where they exposed some
termites to the resin and the other were
the plain water and recorded whether the
termite survived
the explanatory variable that is a
treatment variable is exposure type
resin plain water and the response
variable is whether or not the termite
survived
we can say that this is an experiment
because the researchers imposed a
treatment on the subjects
this can be termed as an experimental
study
statistics is a very large
and deep topic and the three types of
studies form the basics of any
statistical analysis
i hope you like this video if yes
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
and hit that like button we'll see you
in the next video
until then thank you and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here